the cops had told us we had to move
because the Superbowl 50 is coming
through and there's gonna be too many
people and nobody wants to see your tent
when they're coming off the offering the
Super Bowl has come to San Francisco but
before all this moved in a few dozen
people were calling this park home
earlier this summer the San Francisco
Mayor Ed Lee straight-up said homeless
people we're gonna have to leave this
area but where are they supposed to go
san Francisco's homeless population is
about 7,000 people but there's only one
shelter bed for about every five people
who could use one and it's not just this
part that people are being shooed away
from we're hearing from homeless people
that they're being told to leave popular
tourist destinations throughout this
city we're near the cities kind of
bougie Design District but really more
importantly we're under the freeway here
and out of sight of the million or so
tourists that are coming to San
Francisco to get in on the madness this
is the Super Bowl Village you won't see
they're about half a mile attention with
hundreds of people living on the street
out of side of the festivities some say
it's because of rain some say it's
because of the Super Bowl it could be
both more than anything they've just
wanted to appear like seven cities
a poverty time
they come up here and say well you got
to be past this street because of the
super walk so is the city ordering
homeless people to leave tourists is
that the thing that I've heard from the
mayor or some police and in fact the
clear with frontline officers and I both
work that we need to really work
together and to have a compassionate
response the city says that they are
pushing people out of the tourist areas
because of the Superbowl is that is that
just that's a lie okay they are
I understand more I came to the
Coalition on homelessness where they've
been working with the homeless for
nearly 30 years
so if there is this kind of unofficial
mandate to remove homeless people from
these popular tourist areas where are
they supposed to go that's the problem
is is that they don't have anywhere to
go and they simply get displaced they
lose their property they get tickets
what happens is they can't pay their
tickets and that ends up destroying
their credit it ends up turning to
warrants they get jailed when they get
jailed they lose their property also and
so the efforts actually make it harder
for people to exit homelessness
you